African bees are renowned to be very
vicious and elephants are terrified
because they literally don't want to
have a bee of their trunk stinging them
elephants tend to rest under very big
trees and if there is a natural beehive
the elephants will hear the bees
beginning to buzz and they will retreat
or stop doing what they're doing they
know that the bees when disturbed will
swarm and sting knowing that elephants
are scared of bees means that we can
actually save elephants elephants are
one of the most destructive animals in
Africa they are very very hard to manage
in control because they're so big nests
so intelligent and they eat a lot if you
put up beehives in areas where elephants
like to raid forms we can actually
create a barrier between people and
elephants are using bees we can also
take advantage of the fact that is just
the sound of the bees that the elephants
are aware of so we can use instruments
that make that sound like drones
to actually chase elephants away from
places where they could cause a lot of
damage bees and look buzzing in a fear
of bees being used to keep elephants
safe it's very cool all bees buzzed but
bumblebees are one of the very few types
of bees that actually take that buzzing
sound and use it like a secret weapon to
get pollen